[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: Google I/O
is just around the corner.
MALE SPEAKER: And we're
really excited to show you
what we've been cooking up.
MALE SPEAKER: For the
first time, in addition to
our live streams, we are
rolling out over 100 I/O Bytes.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Short
videos help developers
like you dive in.
MALE SPEAKER: And experience
I/O anytime, anywhere.
FEMALE SPEAKER: We're
delivering more content.
MALE SPEAKER: And making it
easier than ever to design,
FEMALE SPEAKER: develop,
FEMALE SPEAKER: and distribute.
MALE SPEAKER: And making
it even more accessible.
MALE SPEAKER: And
it's all for you.
MALE SPEAKER: It's just for you.
MALE SPEAKER: It's
all just for you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]